zum politischen tagesgespräch begrüße
ich heute christian lindner
denn den fdp-vorsitzenden gut tag nach
berlin
hallo einen schönen guten tag nach boden
herr lindner sie haben den ausschnitt
gerade gesehen vielleicht die sendung
mit der kanzlerin gestern auch gesehen
sie will nicht zusehen wie die zahl der
infizierten auf 100000 steigt wie sie
selbst sagt ob womit rechnen sie jetzt
wird denn diesen worten wenden diesen
worten auch taten folgen
niemand möchte zu sehen wie die
infektionszahlen steigen und niemand
möchte vor allen dingen zu sehen wie
eine überlastung unseres
gesundheitswesens drehen könnte drohen
könnte
deshalb ist jetzt nicht die zeit für
vage ankündigungen es ist auch jetzt
nicht die zeit um ministerpräsidenten
wie herrn hans oder herr laschet in die
schranken zu verweisen
das hat frau merkel gestern ja getan
jetzt geht es um maßnahmen es geht jetzt
darum miteinander zu beraten welche
schritte getan werden können um auf das
pandemie geschehen zu antworten ohne die
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
folgeschäden weiter zu vergrößern diese
debatte muss jetzt geführt werden und
zwar sehr konkret auf der ebene von
maßnahmen ihre kollegin katrin göring
eckardt von den grünen gleichfalls
fraktionschefin im bundestag fordert die
bundesregierung auf ein wellenbrecher
plan vorzulegen
sie sagt so geht es nicht weiter die
kontakte müssen reduziert werden wie
sehr denn ihr plan ausländer in dieser
situation wo die zahlen so hochgehen
ja was heißt sehen was sieht er vor wir
haben ja einen entsprechenden plan
vorgelegt erstens wir müssen regional
auf das pandemie geschehen antworten
nicht so wie die grünen das wollen mit
flächendeckenden und pauschalen
freiheits einschränkungen sondern vor
ort bezogen auf das pandemie geschehen
dabei sollten wir die mahnung des
landkreistages also der praktikerinnen
und praktiker sehr ernst nehmen
die empfohlen haben weg zu gehen von der
reinen orientierung auf die sieben tage
incidents
und statt dessen etwa auch die belegung
der krankenhausbetten im intensivbereich
zu berücksichtigen zu fragen wer sich
infiziert welche bevölkerungsgruppe und
auf welche art zweiter massive
beschleunigung des impfens mit mehr
pragmatismus
wir sollten keine impfdosen mehr als
reserve zurücklegen sondern in erwartung
steigender liefermengen jetzt alles was
an im kapazität da es zu nutzen empfehle
ich hausärztinnen und fachärzte
einbinden und gegebenenfalls den
zeitpunkt zwischen der bereits
schützenden ersten impfung und der
zweiten impfung zeitlich auseinander
ziehen
nicht zuletzt sollte astrazeneca das
gegen sich leider auf grund von
kommunikationsfehlern vertrauen
eingebüßt hat und nicht so stark
nachgefragt wird das sollte an alle
abgegeben werden die sich freiwillig
melden und zum dritten massive
ausweitung der tests und der ffp zwei
masken der pflicht
das kann ein instrument sein um in
unserem täglichen miteinander im leben
die gefahren zu reduzieren und
gleichzeitig schafe lockt uns zu
verhindern also sie sind für
differenziert differenzierte lösungen
geradezu für regionalisierte lösungen
herr lindner trotzdem der ruf nach
zentralen lösungen in dieser situation
wird lauter wir können uns zusammen mal
einen kurzen o ton von markus söder von
gestern anschauen
wir brauchen jetzt weniger
flickenteppich als vielmehr eine
entschlossene entscheidung denn im
moment wird dann die frage gestellt wird
diese pandemie eine halbe ewigkeit
dauern die neue welle bis in den sommer
hinein oder können wir sie früher
bekämpfen
und da bin ich eher für sehr konsequente
und klare maßnahmen statt für ein
ständiges hin und her ich hätte mir mehr
kompetenzen des bundes über das
infektionsschutzgesetz vorstellen können
dass die länder auch zu klaren regeln
zwingt ich bin dass er da führen offen
ich tue das ja nicht nur in meiner
funktion als minister über für den
sondern auch als csu vorsitzender der in
der regierungskoalition sitzt also die
länder zu klaren regelungen zwingen in
anführungsstrichen übersetzt das mal so
auf meine art und weise glauben sie dass
es dazu kommen wird
man muss zwei dinge unterscheiden zum
einen die rechtliche situation
die kompetenzen nach meinem dafürhalten
nutzt die bundesregierung nutzt die
bundeskanzlerin bisher ihre rechtlichen
möglichkeiten überhaupt gar nicht auf
insofern ist für mich noch rätselhaft
was genau herr söder meint die
bundesregierung hätte mehr rechtliche
möglichkeiten die nicht genutzt werden
was meinte also damit zusätzliche
kompetenzen an den bund zu geben ich bin
übrigens hier in der sache der meinung
dass wir vor allen dingen einmal eine
vernünftige befassung des parlaments
bräuchten frau merkel möge doch einmal
vor den bundestag treten und in einer
regierungserklärung klar machen wie sie
die lage sieht auf welcher grundlage sie
entscheiden was ihre vorschläge sind wir
erleben doch jetzt wieder leider das was
wir schon seit monaten verfolgen konnten
es gibt in den medien nicht im parlament
ankündigungen aber es passiert nichts
man kann davon ausgehen dass im
kanzleramt jetzt schon papiere verfasst
werden und die werden dann nach ostern
plötzlich öffentlich und dann wird man
mit den ministerpräsidenten wieder wie
zuletzt in einem halb öffentlichen halb
vertraulichen verfahren sprechen und
dann werden die menschen dort von einer
tatsachen gestellt das kann man doch
nicht ein weiteres mal in dieser form
machen und die zweite frage neben also
der kompetenzfrage die also da
aufgerufen hat stelle ich mir die frage
was denn genau in der sache beabsichtigt
ist
die ausgangssperre über die immer wieder
gesprochen werden die sind nicht nur ein
unverhältnismäßiger eingriff in die
freiheit die sind auch epidemiologisch
unwirksam wenn sie und ich wenn wir
beide am späten abend oder am frühen
morgen mit den menschen mit denen wir in
häuslicher gemeinschaft zusammenleben an
der frischen luft allein nicht um den
block gehen können was ist denn daran
für das infektionsgeschehen gewonnen um
es einzugrenzen das ist also eine symbol
maßnahme die nichts bringt und die ich
deshalb außerordentlich kritisch sehe
also das rufen nach staatlichem handeln
das ist das eine aber auf der anderen
seite helena stelle ich mir in diesen
tagen durchaus die frage ob nicht die
gesellschaft mehr tun muss belegt dafür
dient vielleicht die tatsache dass ja
immer mehr regionen und städte und
gemeinden zum modellregionen
werden wollen wo also mit hilfe von
tests und apps geöffnet wird allein in
bayern haben sich mehr als 80 regionen
beworben um aufgenommen zu werden in die
liste der modellregion herr lindner
haben wir hat die gesellschaft haben die
bürgermeisterin und bürger die
geschäftsleute einfach zu viel auf das
staatliche handeln gewartet ich stimme
ihnen zu und ja ich glaube dass ihre
frage schon ein hinweis enthält für eine
dauerhaft durch haltbare strategie wir
müssen mehr vertrauen in die bürgerinnen
und bürger setzen die in der ganz großen
zahl verantwortungsbewusst vernünftig
und rücksichtsvoll sind die die masken
tragen die sich an die regeln halten
wir müssen mehr vertrauen setzen in die
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister vor
ort die das örtliche geschehen genau
einschätzen können die direkten und
indirekten kontakt mit den menschen
haben die wissen was kann ich auf der
einen seite zumuten und was muss ich
zumuten und was ist zu viel und nicht
zuletzt fitnessstudios restaurants der
handeln
wir haben alle hygiene konzepte
entwickelt niemand hat die die gefahren
dort unterschätzter im gegenteil da ist
eine große sensibilität kein besitzer
eines geschäfts oder eines restaurants
will dass bei ihm ein infektionsherd
beklagt werden muss das hat ja enorm ruf
enormen reputationsschaden also insofern
gibt es da viel sensibilität viel
verantwortungsbewusstsein und diese
kugel hygiene konzepte
die haben doch vertrauen verdient im
umkehrschluss sehen wir ja dass der
wellenbrecher lockdown den wir im grunde
seit november haben dass der nicht die
wirkung erzielt hat die wir erhofft
haben weil der eigentliche schlüssel
daran liegt dass menschen im alltag sich
an die regeln halten das tun sie wenn
sie die regeln für vernünftig erachten
nicht für überzogen
wenn wir hygiene konzepte haben und wenn
getestet und geimpft wird
stichwort vertrauen herr lindner zum
schluss die union ist im freien fall in
den umfragen sie liegt an diesem
wochenende bei 25 prozent schauen sie
das als fdp chef
mit einem gewissen lächeln und vergnügen
an oder sagen sie moment mal hier kommt
irgendwann der punkt wo die stabilität
des landes vielleicht gefährdet sein
könnte mir ist schadenfreude fremd ich
bin selber jetzt so lange vorsitzender
meiner partei dass ich schon viele auf
und ab in meiner partei bewältigen
müssen mit meiner partei und deshalb
keine schadenfreude wenn andere in einer
schwierigen situation sind aber die
entwicklung meiner partei hat mich auch
1 gelehrt die situation kann sich auch
schnell wieder verändern und deshalb
messe ich aktuellen umfragen nicht so
viel bedeutet und bei uns konkret zu
machen mit blick auf die spekulationen
der bild zeitung heute es wird ja allen
taten jetzt gesprochen über eine grün
geführte ampel da empfehle ich uns
einfach mal miteinander zu sprechen
welchen weg das land gehen soll
ich bin jedenfalls nicht der überzeugung
dass eine mehrheit in deutschland einen
linksruck will mit noch mehr staatliche
eingriff noch mehr umverteilung noch
mehr schulden und höheren belastungen
deshalb halte ich gegenwärtig auch die
bundestagswahl noch für völlig offen da
sollte niemand sich zu früh siegessicher
sein niemanden sollte man aber auch zu
früh abschreiben sagt christian lindner
der fdp-vorsitzende ich sage vielen dank
für ihre zeit und eine schöne töne woche
nach berlin ihnen auch alles gute bis
bald